Speaker 1: OK, this is super interesting.
There are hundreds of cases against alleged
Trump rioters from January six right now,
hundreds of cases.
There has now been a decision by the judge
in the case to release the police interrogation
video of one of the accused rioters.
A man named Danny Rodriguez, Danny Rodriguez.
Many in my audience thought this was like
a kid, like barely an adult.
I did, too.
Turns out it's a 38 year old man.
Danny Rodriguez has admitted to being the
individual who tased Officer Michael Fanone,
who was one of the three or four officers
who testified before the committee investigating
the Jan. six riots.
We're going to look at some clips of the police
interviews, some call them interrogations,
and they are interesting in a number of ways
in terms of the police interviewing techniques,
they're all completely standard.
When I streamed some of these clips yesterday,
there were people in the chat saying Everything
here is crazy that the police are doing another
saying This is all totally standard.
Everything that happens here is completely
standard.
It doesn't mean we like all of it, but it
is all completely standard.
Let's jump in.
Here is when he is first.
Read his Miranda rights and Danny Rodriguez
says, You know, I'm always told I'm not supposed
to talk.
Speaker 2: I want to talk to you guys.
And in the past, lawyers have always told
me, You know, you don't say anything to help
you.
Well, by signing this, you're just acknowledging
that you were read your rights and that you're
willing to talk to us at this time just because
you signed.
It doesn't mean any of these rights go away.
These rights are always with you throughout
the entire process that you're in the legal
system, OK?
Does that make
Speaker 1: sense?
All right, so totally standard.
Danny Signs acknowledges that he's been read
his rights and then does proceed to talk,
although he seems sort of hesitant in this
next moment.
The officers do something that's very, very
typical, and I'm not saying this is good or
bad.
It's very, very typical.
They say, Listen.
We want your side of the story, because right
now we're getting everybody else's side.
And we want your side of the story.
The implication is always that you can help
yourself by telling your side of the story.
Now, defense lawyers will tell you it's never
in your interest to just start talking in
this way.
You really want to make them have to prove
their case against you.
Now, this guy ultimately admits what he did,
and there's video evidence and whatever, but
just merely, you know, four people saying,
Oh, well, he's big trick.
This is typical.
We want to hear your side of the story.
Every defense attorney I know would say, Get
a lawyer, don't say a word and get a lawyer.
Speaker 2: This is an opportunity here for
you to let us know and help us understand,
because right now we don't we don't frankly
understand exactly what happened from your
perspective, right?
And I think that there's an opportunity here
for us to get clarity on what what went down.
Speaker 1: And these are always the terms
that investigators use.
This is an opportunity for you.
Most people here opportunity that that sounds
good we can get.
We can clear this up.
Let's clear this up and good police interviewers
already have the clarity they need from evidence
and other people they've spoken to.
And what they mean by clarity is getting you
to admit that this is the thing that you did.
So then they get on to some pretty interesting
substantive substantive stuff's substantive
stuff.
Why did Danny Rodriguez start going to rallies
in the first place, Trump rallies and other
right wing rallies?
Well, among other things, it was Alex Jones
and Infowars.
Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: Hmm.
Speaker 3: And so I think that's kind of what
what I'm trying to like understand.
Speaker 2: I don't know what happened here
is
Speaker 3: I want to know that Danny, though
I want to know.
I want to know that, Danny, that, you know,
that kind of intervened in that situation.
And I want to know how that Danny got to January
six.
Speaker 2: Your story is an important story.
I just picked it.
Oh, and
Speaker 1: by the way, that line your story
is an important story.
I got a couple of emails from defense lawyers
who said without saying anything about this
particular guy, oftentimes people in these
situations.
Don't.
Really understand what's going on and that
the detectives are there only if they believe
you did it to be able to build that case against
you to ultimately have this go to trial and
get a conviction.
This idea of your story is an important story.
More sophisticated individuals, I mean, listen,
if I was sitting there, I would go stop blowing
smoke were, you know, you know, where an important
story?
What do I look like an idiot to you?
An import?
I mean, it's just it's an it's.
But it works.
And that's why they say stuff like this is
an important story.
Speaker 2: It crazy or like a conspiracy theorist
because you guys are going to come out and
nobody get locked up because I believe this
and put me in jail.
OK.
Speaker 1: So continuing to ask those questions,
and he does, for the most part, continue talking
about it.
And then they get to this part about Alex
Jones.
Let's take a listen to that.
Speaker 2: We've done this for a long time.
We've talked to, like I told you, we talked
to a lot of people and a lot of people are
worried about being judged when they talk
to law enforcement that we're going to have
an opinion.
And I'm telling you right now we don't we
don't hold judgment over you.
We want you to be the jury and the judge is
going to be listening to you even even as
a fellow human being, right?
That's what we're telling you is we're looking
at you today as a fellow human, as a fellow
citizen of this country, as somebody who has
lived here, complete investment into this
country of your work and you're you grew up
here.
And look, I don't have any loyalty to any
other country.
This is the very good.
This is all you do and this is all I want
and I don't care about any other part of the
world except for our team.
So how how did Danny get stood on the line
in between law enforcement and in chief of
BLM?
How did you get get to that point?
What happened to your life?
Like, how did you start going to these rallies?
It is, and just.
So like Alex Jones stuff.
Yeah.
OK.
Speaker 1: Alex Jones and Infowars is what
started to radicalize him in this direction.
Now may be the most contentious aspect of
this is that his lawyers are now claiming
he signaled he didn't want to talk by shaking
his head at one point during the interview.
I'm going to show that to you, and this is
pretty early on.
And so his lawyer is asking that everything,
including the eventual confession I'm going
to play for you, be thrown out now.
I'm going to play the video for you where
he shakes his head.
He absolutely shakes his head very slightly.
And then he does continue talking.
I'm going to tell you in a moment the case
that his lawyers are making if you're watching.
It's all I've had to watch it 10 times to
even see this.
He very, very slightly shakes his head here.
OK, so let's pay very close attention and
see if you can spot it.
Speaker 2: And you want to talk about that?
Speaker 1: OK, so he's asked, do you want
to talk about that?
It's a very, very slight head shake.
Very, very slight.
I'll play it one more time.
It's barely visible
Speaker 2: and you want to talk about that.
Because I'll tell you what.
Everybody else is going to talk about that.
Yeah, I'm pretty intrigued.
Speaker 1: So what happens is he's asked,
Do you want to talk about that?
It's a very slight handshake.
And then he's told everyone else is going
to talk about it.
And then he says, Well, I'm ashamed.
And then he continues talking.
It's incredibly subtle.
The argument that his lawyers are making is
everything after that is inadmissible because
when a suspect says they don't want to talk,
they can resume talking under their own choice.
But they have to be the ones doing it.
And this is the argument his lawyers are making.
And because the detective then said, Well,
everyone else is going to talk about it.
The lawyers are saying that is continuing
to question him, even though it's not literally
a question that they continued, even though
he shook his head this.
I spoke to a couple of defense lawyers.
They they're saying this is very, very 50-50,
but that if they had to guess, this is not
going to be a confession that is thrown out
on the basis of that slight handshake.
But that's what his lawyers are arguing for
now.
Then you get to a key moment, which is where
he says, Yes, I tased him.
He tased Officer Fanone.
This is sort of like the key moment of the
confession.
Speaker 2: OK, what?
What, what?
What do you want me to tell you that I teach
them?
Yes.
Explain.
Why did you take them?
I don't know.
I'm sorry.
You know, he's a human being with children.
And he is.
He's not a bad guy.
He sounds like he's just doing his job.
Speaker 1: And so here it starts to sound
like there's some aspect of remorse.
I'll get back to that.
Here, he says he was in D.C. because as far
as he knew, Trump called them to D.C..
Speaker 2: How do you get to January six?
Okay.
What's what else happens in that period of
time?
Troconis, did you see?
Tell me about that and how did he let you
guys know to come to D.C.?
If he's the commander in chief and the leader
of our country, he's calling for it.
He was hoping for hope.
I thought he was doing the right thing.
So we were just I had no plans of what was
going to happen.
I didn't know what was going to happen.
Speaker 1: So he believed Trump was calling
them.
He believed Trump was calling him.
And then it did get emotionally escalated.
And there was kind of this kind of breakdown
feel to it.
Speaker 2: Danny, did you feel like you were
the three percent here?
Like, like like those people that stormed
the Capitol, that those are patriots, those
are people who are doing that because they
were the three percent that were going to
free our country from fraudulent politicians
and schemes of evil people.
So that way we could have a republic that
was going to be whole again.
So how much you thought you thought you were
that three percent?
I know.
Yeah, I know.
It's OK.
I'm sorry.
You know, we we know, we know you thought
that you were that three percent, Gary.
Sorry.
I do.
Speaker 1: So this is interesting for a number
of different reasons.
One, this is just one story of the hundreds.
There are hundreds of people like this who
they believe that they were patriots.
They believe Trump was calling them to D.C.
They believe they were doing the right thing
by tasering or tasing a police officer and
on and on and on number two, in moments, he
sort of seems remorseful.
But then in other moments, you realize he
actually is and he talks about he and his
patriots is they're going to be room in the
jail for the number of patriots that are there.
He still continues to insist that they were
doing, generally speaking, the right thing.
So.
What this one story tells us, I don't know,
but understand that when we say stochastic
terrorism, people see these messages, all
this different stuff, and it leads to real
world action.
It very much does, and every single one of
them now is a case involving investigators,
the judicial system, et cetera.
And the people who incited this stuff, at
least so far, have suffered no consequences
whatsoever.
We're going to follow this case and others
as they go forward